- Notre gouvernement va lancer
des cons
2022.
- Ottawa veut explorer de
nouvelles idées pour réformer
la Loi sur la non-divulgation
L'objectif : moderniser
le système de justice canadien
comme le souhaitent des groupes
de militants, qui réclament que
personnes vivant avec le VIH.
Me PATRICK MARTIN-MÉNARD
avocat en droit civil
- Essentiellement, une personne
lors qu'il existe une possiblité
réaliste de transmsision du VIH
lors de rapport sexuel.
Le g
c'est qu'il n'y a pas une
définition précise de ce qu'est
de transmission.
- Depuis 1989, le Réseau
200 personnes séropositives
qui ont été accusées pour ne pas
avoir partagé leur statut.
être portées en lien avec ça
sont exccessivment graves,
on parle d'agressions sexuelles
- Le Dr Jean-Pierre Routy
déplore que les lois actuelles
criminalisent les personnes
des cas où la possibilité
de transmission est faible,
voire inexistante.
Conférence sur le sida 2022
- Si la personne est bien
traitée, il n'y pas de risque
la loi doit changer.
La criminalisation ne correspond
pas aux données de la science.an
a de lourdes répercussions
sur la vie des personnes vivant
avec le virus.uéuéuéuéuéuéuéuéus
plusieurs procès comme expert,
et ce qui est étonnant,
c'est que la personne qui porte,
mais elle porte plainte souvent
dans des moments de divorce,
de séparation, juste pourêêêêêê,
alors qu'elle n'est pas
infectée.
- Le simple fait de l'avoi
exposé aux risques est
suffisant, et ça, c'est une
des problématiques q
souvent dénoncée.
- Ça va trop loin, c'est trop
exagéré. Seign
maladie, c'est une maladie.
- Dans le Village gai de
Montréal, plusieurs estiment
que les n.n.n.n.n.n.n.n.n.n.n.n.
- Qu'il y ait une loi là-dessus,
ça,  s suis pas d'accord. Moi,
je trouve qu'on devrait éduquer
la population.
le respect avec la personne,
surtout s'il y a des risques
pour la santé de l'autre
personne.
cet automne permettront du moins
d'd'apporter un peu de clarté
au débat.
JEAN-YVES DUCLOS,
- ...qui viseront à recueillir
l'avis des intervenants et
du public sur la meilleure façon
de moderniser la réponse
du système- - - - - - - - - - -5
million de nouvelles infections
au VIH ont été rapportées
en 2021, soit plus de 4000
Ici Hadi Hassin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.